Game of Thrones Season 6 Episode 3 is out,
and there a heap to talk about so let’s
begin.
At the Wall, Jon Snow rises from the dead,
and people think he’s “the prince that
was promised”, or “Azor Ahai reborn”,
a messianic figure prophesied to save the
world from darkness – basically kind of
a Game of Thrones Jesus – and Jon is pretty
Jesus-y, isn’t he? A righteous man betrayed
by his friends, killed before a cross, risen
from the dead, great hair, sweet abs. It’s
not super clear what being this saviour means,
but it seems to involve fighting the white
walkers and their wights. Also, Melisandre
asks Jon where he went and what he saw when
he was dead, and Jon says “nothing”. Mel
has a similar exchange with Beric Dondarrion
when he’s resurrected three seasons ago. Maybe part of why Melisandre is so interested
in death is that she herself has been fleeing
death for apparently “several centuries”, maybe
she fears death, and that’s why she asks
about it so intently. Anyway the similarity
between Beric and Jon suggests that their
resurrections work by the same kinda magic.
But when Beric is resurrected, he changes,
loses bits of his memories and identity. When
Jon comes back, all it takes is one of Davos’
legendary pep talks, and then he seems about
the same as he ever was. So is Jon truly unchanged
by death? Or will we see new sides to his
character this season?
Then we’re on a ship sailing south. We see
Gilly being cute, and Sam being not so cute.
The plan is for Sam to join the maesters at
the Citadel in Oldtown, which is sort of like
a university, where Sam can learn the knowledge
he needs to help the Watch – maybe he’ll
find some info on white walkers. But since
the Citadel doesn’t accept women, Sam will
be dropping Gilly and the baby off at Horn
Hill, with Sam’s family. He mentions his
mother Melessa is “kind”, and his sister
Talla is “lovely”, but his father Randyll
is neither. As Sam explained in Season 1,
Randyll was horrible to Sam growing up – cursing,
caning, slapping and starving him to try to
toughen him up into the strong, brave son
he wanted, instead of the soft, cowardly son
he got. Eventually Randyll threatened to kill
Sam unless he gave up his name and inheritance,
which is how Sam ended up joining the Watch. And now Sam is coming home, bringing Gilly,
and her baby, who they’re saying is Sam’s
when it’s actually Craster’s – Mance’s
in the books cause there’s a baby-swap plot
– but the point is that this is gonna be
an epically awkward Meet the Parents type
situation, except that De Niro is a battle-hardened
war veteran, Ben Stiller is a fat Watchman
who killed an ice monster, and his girlfriend
is a wildling with an incest-baby, so this
is gonna go off. On another note, in the show,
Maester Aemon died last season at the Wall,
but in the books Maester Aemon comes along
with Sam and Gilly on this voyage, and he
dies on board the ship. There’s this beautiful
moving scene with Aemon crying in the rain,
remembering his youth, depicted here by artist
Kay Haung – see the link in the description
for more of his art.
Then beyond the Wall, Bran has a vision of
the Tower of Joy. This event happened about
twenty years ago, at the time of Robert’s
Rebellion, the war where Robert Baratheon
took over Westeros from the Mad King Aerys
Targaryen, after the Mad King’s son Prince
Rhaegar ran off with Ned Stark’s sister
Lyanna, who we saw as a child last episode.
At this point in the war, both the Mad King,
and Prince Rhaegar have been killed, so Ned
Stark and a group of his men, including Meera
and Jojen’s father Howland Reed, have come
looking for Lyanna at the Tower of Joy. They
find the Tower guarded by three Kingsguard
– two Kingsguard in the show – including
the legendary swordsman Arthur Dayne – the
Sword of the Morning. They talk about the
war – the dialogue is kinda cooler in the
books – and then they fight, with Dayne
pretty much kicking all their asses. He would’ve
killed Ned too if Howland hadn’t stabbed
him in the back at the last moment, so that
Ned could finish Dayne off. It’s upsetting
for Bran to see his father act in this dishonourable
way – Ned had this seemingly untouchable
reputation of honour and honesty , but if
he didn’t tell the whole truth about what
happened with Dayne, what else might he have
hidden? It’s also interesting to see Howland
wounded – maybe that’s related to why
he hasn’t turned up yet in the series – cause
he is alive, at least in the books – he’s
the last living survivor of the Tower of Joy,
and people keep saying how great he is, but
we still haven’t seen him. Maybe he was
disabled by this wound somehow and has to
stay at home? Either way we’ll hopefully
see more of him soon, there are lots of cool
theories about him. Anyway after the fight,
we start getting to the important bit – Ned
hears screaming from the Tower, which is presumably
Lyanna, because that’s who he came to find
– but we don’t know what’s up – like,
is she in pain? is she dying? is she alone
up there? Just as we’re about to find out
the “raven” pulls Bran out of the vision.
So it looks like we’ll have to wait a couple
more episodes to see what happened in the
tower – but there are some huge old theories
about this – check out the R+L=J video for
details. But another thing we learn here is
that Bran can affect the past through his
visions – he calls out to Ned, and Ned hears
him. This could support the idea that Wylis
became Hodor when Bran somehow messed with
his mind in one of these visions, like, maybe
Bran says Hodor to young Wylis, and that’s
where the name Hodor originally comes from,
like some kinda timey-wimey Back to the Future
circular paradox type shit. And the point
of this for Bran’s character, could be to
show him the terrible potential of his power,
to give him guilt, and the restraint, that
Bloodraven is trying to teach him. At the
end of the scene Bran asks Bloodraven what
the point of all this training is and he vaguely
but dramatically says to learn everything.
Daenerys Targaryen arrives at Vaes Dothrak,
the sacred city of the Dothraki, and she’s
actually been here before, way back Season
1, when she eats that horse heart. She meets
the dosh khaleen, the widows of dead khals,
who strip her and demean her and tell her
that that she may or may not be made to join
their happy little retirement village, depending
on the results of a big meeting of all the
Dothraki khalasars together. That might sound
bad for Dany – but having all the Dothraki
in one place with Dany’s dragon on the way
– might actually be an opportunity to take
control of a massive Dothraki army. This will
probably involve some Dothraki getting barbequed
– and this this dosh khaleen woman is probably
first on Dany’s list.
In Meereen, Varys questions Vala, the woman
we saw working with the Sons of the Harpy
last season. Varys seems to play nice, offering
silver and passage to Pentos in return for
information on the Harpy. He says he doesn’t
torture and wouldn’t hurt a child. But is
this really how Varys operates? We know he
lies, manipulates and kills – will he really
keep his promises to Valla, or will he dispose
of her once he has what he wants? There’s
a lot of moral complexity to Varys, at least
in the books – hopefully the show will reflect
some of that. Anyway so Valla tells Varys
that the Sons of the Harpy are funded by three
cities – Astapor, Yunkai and Volantis – which
makes sense, because those cities trade slaves,
and Dany banned slavery. When Varys tells
this to Tyrion, Missandei and Grey Worm, there’s
talk of war between Meereen and these other
cities.
In King’s Landing, we see the creepy Qyburn
with Varys’ spies, the children he calls
“little birds”. In the books, these children
are mute – Varys has their tongues removed
so they can’t share his secrets, but here,
the birds say Varys is nice, and gives him
sweets, like a Santa Claus with no balls,
so yeah maybe the show is turning Varys into
more of a one-dimensional good guy, which
would be a shame. But the fact the “little
birds” are included at all in the show hints
that they’ll play some future role – in
fact that looks like them in the trailer murdering
a certain someone – for those who’ve read
the books, that might be the scene at the
end of Dance. Then Cersei rolls in with her
entourage of the one-handed Kingslayer and
the zombie-Mountain, she talks about wanting
to kill people, and she mentions the plans
to demand a trial by combat against the Faith,
and that Robert Strong a.k.a. the Mountain
a.k.a. Gregor Clegane will fight for her.
The question, then, is who the champion for
the Faith will be, who could possibly stand
against Robert Strong? Well there is a theory
that a certain Gravedigger may rise to fight
in what’s probably the most hyped hypothetical
fight in the fandom. It’ll be fucking crazy
if it happens, but probably more fun if it’s
a surprise, so let’s move on for now. Cersei
and Jaime try to join the small council, but
Olenna Tyrell the Queen of Sick Burns talks
smack about Cersei’s incest, Mace Tyrell
dithers, Pycelle farts, and Kevan leads the
council out of the room. This is the government
of Westeros, and it’s in a sorry bloody
state. At this point Kevan and maybe Olenna
are the only people really holding things
together. Then we see Tommen confront the
High Sparrow, all like ‘I’m an angry Lannister,
hear me roar, I make violent threats just
like my mum’, and the High Sparrow is like
nah mate you’re not a lion, you’re a kitten,
now sit down, and let’s have a chat about
Jesus, and Tommen’s like yeah okay let’s
do that. Try as he might, Tommen just isn’t
intimidating or cruel like his parents, he’s
sensitive – and the Sparrow knows exactly
how to play him. Just like he undermines Cersei
by exploiting her pride and her body and sexuality,
and undermines Jaime by showing that his physical
power is useless, he controls Tommen by targeting
his insecurities about his relationship with
his mother, and his responsibilities as king.
Tommen is a kid in need of guidance, in need
of a good father figure – the High Sparrow
sees this and provides – carefully drawing
Tommen in to his own ideology and control.
The High Sparrow is not just a holy man – he’s
a master manipulator – so what’s his endgoal?
In Braavos, Arya gets a training montage – “Montage!”
She uses her senses to overcome her blindness,
she detects poisons by smell, she plays the
lying game and ultimately becomes a stronger
person. She subtly threatens the waif, and
gives her a good smack in the face, so they’re
really setting the groundwork here for conflict
between the two. Eventually a Man with Jaqen’s
face turns up and for the first time this
season we see this Jaqen and the waif together
in the same room, showing that there are at
least two Faceless Men around, not just one
swapping faces. In the books there seem to
be at least nine of them in total – maybe
that’s true in the show as well. Anyway,
in the end, Arya gets her sight back. The
blind part of training is over and she’s
ready to go kick arse. Whose arse, we don’t
yet know.
Then Lord Smalljon Umber turns up at Winterfell.
He’s there to join up with Ramsay, but he
doesn’t kneel, doesn’t swear oaths, he
calls Ramsay’s dad a coont and sees right
through his lies, so right away Ramsay’s
rightly suspicious of this guy – why should
he trust him? Umber gives Ramsay a gift – Rickon,
the youngest Stark brother, who everyone forgot
about, and Osha, the wildling who protected
him after they split from Bran. Since everyone
thinks Bran is dead, Rickon is the last known
surviving male Stark, making him the rightful
Lord of Winterfell – and a very valuable
captive for Ramasy – especially after losing
Sansa. To show that the kid really is Rickon,
Umber presents the head of Shaggydog, Rickon’s
direwolf, which… is really sad. Shaggy was
there for Rickon when no one else was, he
represents Rickon’s anger and wildness,
and he showed so much promise – in the books
there’s a vision of Shaggy fighting a unicorn
on Skagos, people hoped to see Rickon ride
Shaggydog into battle at Winterfell – this
wolf was just really metal and cool so it’s
sad to see him go. But it is funny that, in
storytelling, a shaggy dog story is a long
story that ends up being pointless or anticlimactic,
so arguably Shaggydog himself is a sort of
a shaggydog story. Unless it’s not really
Shaggy – some people have pointed out that
the head looks kinda small for a direwolf,
so maybe it’s just a normal wolf’s head,
and the Umbers are secretly still loyal to
the Starks – but this might just be wishful
thinking, cause in the second trailer, that
is an Umber banner flying with the Bolton
army. So if anyone’s up to any Northern
conspiracy shenanigans it’ll probably be
the Manderleys, who Ramsay mentioned in the
last episode. Those guys have some of the
best lines in the series, so get keen for
that. But in the meantime, things don’t
look good for Rickon and Osha.
Back at the Wall, Jon Snow kills the people
who killed him – a kind of revenge that
not many people get to have. It’s actually
kinda cool that Jon hangs them, because if
Jon Snow is Jesus, these guys are like Judas,
and in the Bible, Judas hangs himself , depending
on which passage you read , it’s probably
a coincidence, but still a cool connection.
Anyway it’s hard not to respect Alliser
for standing up for what he believed until
the very end. He just wanted to protect the
Watch. And Olly – lotta people wanted to
see Olly dead – jokingly mostly, but still
– it’s hard to be happy about a dead kid
isn’t it? The tragedy of all this drama
on the Wall is while these good men squabble
amongst themselves, much greater threats lie
just to the south and north. These are the
real enemies, and right now the Watch isn’t
anywhere near ready. Anyway after killing
his killers, Jon hands command to Edd, and
says his watch is over. Mic drop. The vows
of the Night’s Watch say “it shall not
end until my death”, and since Jon died,
he’s now seen as freed from his vows, which
is kind of a bullshit technicality, maybe
this could be seen as breaking his oath hashtag
episode title, but either way, it looks like
we’re finally getting what’s been wanted
for a long while – Jon’s gonna ride south
to Winterfell.
So this episode wasn’t as massive as the
last two – no resurrections, great revelations,
dead kings or destroyed houses – but there’s
a lot of set-up here for future conflict.
There’s talk of war in Slaver’s Bay, Dany’s
threatening the dosh khaleen with a dragon’s
on the way, a trial by combat is coming in
King’s Landing, and most terrifying of all,
Sam’s bringing his girlfriend home to his
parents. Bran’s getting stroppy with his
teacher, Arya’s getting stroppy with her
teacher, the Boltons have Rickon, and Jon
Snow’s watch is ended.
Thank you for watching, please like and subscribe
if you’d like to see more, and thank you
to all Patrons supporting the channel, including
Sarah Cleary, Spencer Bentley, Ryan Steele,
Sid Yadav, William Armstrong, Amy cobb, Dcxalius
and G. Cheers.